The casinos in Vegas or they're,
they're probably gonna
want to do this fight next.
That's where they want it because they
want all that extra gambling money in
restaurant money and show money. Right.
That's where I would likely, I would,
I would say it's likely gonna wind up,
you know, got a lot of places, you know,
I wouldn't mind going back to
New York as well, garden me,
you know, you got so many
diverse people there, you know,
a lot of people look at travels and
stuff like that, you know, all those,
it'd be busy and stuff. You
know, people want it still
to be easy access. He, Vegas,
Vegas makes it easy for
people because you know,
the airport is right there and then five
minutes away you're on the Strip and
that's what most of the people be
at and stuff. But you know, we're,
we'll see when the time comes.
You know, I'm open for any, any,
any place you go when you guys
talking about a rematch maybe, uh,
we're looking at April, May, June,
somewhere up in there, you know, and uh,
we'll see what happens. I'm
excited though. You know,
he said he back in the gym,
he t he hit me up.
He sent me a video saying how you
back in the gym and stuff like that.
And I just hit back him.
Likewise because it's crazy because his
mindset is being back in the gym and
mine's is the same way. You know, I been,
I been traveling a lot talking about this
fight. Like it's been like I'm already,
you know, it in discussion with
certain outlets or whatever.
It's like we've been boosting up this
net, this rematch fight. Like it's, it's,
it's almost here.
It's been crazy though.
This is what my career needed as well
too, you know? Um, so I don't mind,
I'd been from La to New York.
I'm just getting from New York now.
I'm back here and now offering
to go to my original home time.
I got some things I got to do out
there, enjoy the, the holidays.
I'm going to take a vacation with my
family and then once I get back on back
into the gym myself. Well, boxing fans,
hardcore boxy fans
already knew who you are,
but this was the breakthrough
fight for the general public.
This is a breakthrough fight where people
know about it now and the next fight.
The rematch.
First of all,
you couldn't ask for a better dance
partner when it comes to promotion.
I mean Tyson's fantastic on
the microphone. He's hilarious.
Got that great accent,
listen to him talk.
So you guys promoting this and getting
ready for whenever that April, May, June,
whenever it takes place.
I mean,
this is going to be probably one
of the biggest heavyweight fights,
if not the biggest of all time. Man, I'm
just so excited. You know what I mean?
Because I can see,
I can visualize it now.
I couldn't really visualize
how big this could become.
I knew it was going to be big, but you
just don't know how people are. You know,
people are funny, especially, you know,
people always have things
to do, you know? Nailed it.
There was nothing else competing with you.
There's nothing else there to watch.
It was perfect. It was a perfect
storm and then it was in Atlanta,
so stars came out. It was a
big deal, man. It was amazing.
And I'll never forget it, you
know. Excuse me. Like I said,
I've been waiting for this. I've been
waiting for that moment for so you know,
they don't have this problem in the
UK because no matter, no matter what,
they love boxing.
It's the second nature of sport.
They don't have college sports and
professional sports that they had to deal
with boxes. Like I said, they're
second nature of sport and you know,
Eh, you know, they don't have as
many as people we have here to here.
Like what made me 66 million, something
like that. Uh, Alabama and Mississippi,
they can fit UK in Alabama and
Mississippi combining them together,
but they can fit the whole state
and in Texas and still have space,
which over here we got so much.
We got how many colleges and
professional sports and you know,
boxing is like probably the
last sport, you know, on the
list. You know, I probably,
you know,
exaggerating with that a little bit,
but it definitely seemed like
that we definitely, you know,
in the back and there's so
much to compete with. It's so,
it's so hard here to do it.
And then when you, when you,
when you finally get that shine, you know,
that's where it comes from. You know,
when a minute, and when you're
in it and you understand it,
it's like how it's so hard.
It was to get it to get to this point,
you know, down there 11 years
and like to get to this point.
And then when you finally get
here is like, you were here.